يعني التحقيق لم ينتهي بالتاكيد لكن هل من
تفسير لتاخر اي تصريحات رسميه ولو بشكل
اولي
وهذا ما كنت اريد ان اقوله سفيان بالفعل
لحد الان الكلام صامت صامت بشكل كامل لا
لم لم يتعامل مع هذا الموضوع سوى انه قبل
تقريبا نصف ساعه من الان كان شوهد موكب
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين عائدا من
مدينه كورسك حيث كان في مهمه خارجيه خارج
موسكو واتجه باتجاه الكريم
في هذا الوقت المتاخر احيانا يقوم بوتين
في مثل هذه التحركات خاصه عندما تكون هناك
اشياء كبيره تحدث في البلاد هذا من ناحيه
من ناحيه ثانيه طبعا هناك كان حديث عن عن
بيان سيصدر عن القاده العسكريين او مجلس
القياده العسكريه لشركه فاقدر في خاص في
ما جرى لحدث طائره ربما هذا البيان يعلن
رسميا او يفند مس مقتل او عدم مقتل يفنن
مقتل ولكن كل الاشارات على الاقل الاوليه
الان تتحدث حتى من مصادر داخل شركه تتحدث
على ان عن
القائد العسكري الرئيسي لشركه بالفعل على
متن هذه الطائره وحتى بحسب بيانات هيئه
الملاحه الجويه الروسيه كان علامات
الطائره
ويبدو انه لا يوجد احياء من الاسماء العشر
على الاقل او الذين كانوا موجودين عليها
والان تبقى مساله نتيجه الحريق الكبير
والانفجار الكبير لهذه الطائره يبقى تبقى
مساله التاكد
من خلال الحمض النووي من جثتي
بريجوجن
واوتقن وشخصيات الاخرى التي كانت على مثلا
هذه الطائره المؤكده ان هناك سبعه شخصيات
اضافه الى ثلاث ثلاثه من طاقه مع طائره
شخصيات منها مساعدين مختصين في القضايا
اللوجستيه والمسؤولين عن التحركات
قائد او مالك شركه فاجنر
نعم سفيان هلا اعطيتنا ايضا ربما فكره عن
تناول وتعليق الروس يعني بشان تحطم هذه
الطائره واحتمال ايضا وفاه اذا القدم
مهمين في شركه فاجنر اخص بالذكر هنا
والشكل الجدل الذي يدور في البلاد في هذه
اللحظات
نعم في الحقيقه يمكن تقسيم التعامل
الاعلامي
مع هذه الحادثه الى قسمين وسائل الاعلام
الرسميه وتحديد على القنوات التلفزيونيه
تتعامل بشكل شبهب يعني بارد اقرب الى
البروده مع هذا الحادث تتعامله وكانه خبر
عادي على عكس وسائل الاعلام الاخرى بما
فيها وسائل اعلام مهمه ورئيسيه حكوميه انا
اقصد هنا ليست التلفزيونات وانما وكالات
انباء كاريه نوفسكي واوتاس تتعامل بشكل
كبير وهي وهو ولديها العنوان الاول فيما
يتعلق
بالجدل هو الجدل بدرجه الاولى يدور حول
كيفيه تحطم الطائره جدل يدور حول الطائره
الثانيه التي اقلعت بعد اقلاع الطائره
الاولى بدقائق وبعد التحطم عادت بسرعه
لتهبط بشكل عاجل في احد المطارات في
مقاطعه موسكو هذه المنطقه طبقت بشكل كامل
ليمنع اقتراب الصحفيين او احد الى ذلك
المطار احد يعرف من علاماتن هذه الطائره
الثانيه المعروف ايضا ان الطائره الطائره
الاولى التي من المتوقع ان يكون عليها
تحطمت بعد 26 دقيقه من اقلاعها فوق مقاطعه
السجل الاعلامي هو يدور في درجه الاولى
حول من
الذي يعني تفيده مساله
مقتل بريجوجل في هذا التوقيت بعد شهرين
بالضبط سفيان شهرين بالضبط يفصل حادث
اليوم عن عمليه التمرد العسكري التي قام
بها مجموعه فاقنر في الرابع والعشرين من
يونيو الماضي والتي طبعا كانت ايضا احتلت
العنوان الاول على جميع وسائل الاعلام
المحليه والعالميه اذا هو حادث بدون شك له
دلالات كثيره له صدى كبير خاصه وانا
بريجين في الاشهر
الماضيه كان شخصيه يعني اشكاليه شخصيه
جدليه شخصيه تحدد القياده العسكريه
الروسيه هرم السلطه العسكريه الروسيه
القويه
واتهم بالخيانه العظمى
وكان هذا الاتهام موجها من بوتين بشكل
مباشر الذي كان على مدى سنوات يصنف على
انه من اكثر الشخصيات ولا لرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين على رغم من ان بريجوجين لم
ينتقد بشكل مباشر الرئيس الروسي ولكنه
انتقد اداء القوات العسكريه الروسيه
وقياده القوات الروسيه في حرب اوكرانيا
بوتين ايضا لم ينتقد شركه هو اشاد في وصف
اعمالهم في اوكرانيا بانه وطني وانهم
قاموا بعمل بطوله وانهم خدعوا من قبل
للقيام في هذه المغامره التي
سميتنا في روسيا بالتمرد او محاوله تمرد
عسكري ايضا لابد الاشاره الى ان مج
القياده العسكريه لقوات هذه المعلومات
طبعا معلومات رسميه تضم نحو يضم نحو 30
ضابطا معظمهم جنرالات سابقون في الجيش
الروسي في جهاز الاستخبارات العسكريه
الروسيه 20 منهم عشرون من ثلاثين سفيان
يحملون وسام بطل روسيا وهو اعلى وسام يمنح
في الدوله الروسيه
العسكريين وذلك بسبب معاركهم وخوضهم
وقتالهم في اوكرانيا وهذا له ايضا رمزيه
كبيره هذا الوسام لا يمنح بشكل ارتباط هنا
في روسيا وبالتالي ايضا بالنسبه لموسكو
فاقدر تبقى مؤسسه عسكريه مهمه
انشات من اجل ان تخدم روسيا في كثير من
المستويات في المواقف في المواقع
الجغرافيه المختلفه في العالم وخاصه في
افريقيا